líbano vive la peor crisis económica del
planeta según el banco mundial en este
contexto el miércoles el banco central
libanés anunció que iba a dejar de
subsidiar las importaciones de
combustible una decisión que
multiplicaría el precio por 4
tendremos que robar para llenar nuestras
motocicletas de combustible cuando el
juez pregunte diremos que fue para
combustible comida y bebida porque el
estado no nos da nuestros derechos
básicos
el jueves el gobierno interino respondió
que las ayudas van a continuar y se
empezarán a racionar cuando se
implementen tarjetas pre-pago para las
rentas más bajas antes el presidente
michel a un y parte del gobierno se
reunieron con riad salame gobernador del
banco central este dijo que para
continuar el subsidio se han de utilizar
las reservas obligatorias algo no
previsto en la ley el gobierno busca
sancionar una nueva legislación que lo
permita ante el peligro de retirar las
ayudas
nacional yo nos enfrentamos a una gran
explosión social debido a la decisión
unilateral tomada por el gobernador del
banco central de forma repentina sobre
los subsidios
en el banco central vive retrasos en su
capacidad de subsidiar por la falta de
liquidez
el gobernador apuesta por subsidiar a
los ciudadanos en lugar de comerciantes
y monopolistas los combustibles
subsidiados estarían utilizándose de
contrabando en siria
el lunes ante la escasez de combustible
se produjeron dos peleas en el norte de
líbano que dejaron tres muertos repostar
significa horas de colas los ciudadanos
están desesperados
a medida nos hicieron perder todo en
líbano sin combustible sin electricidad
sin agua sin nada alquilar una casa
cuesta millones a dónde vamos a ir la
moneda se ha devaluado un 90 por ciento
desde 2019 mientras que según las
naciones unidas casi el 80% de la
población vive en la pobreza